这个观点是不对的，
这几百万的存款不是你一个人挣下来，
不是你去给人家还款，
其实某种意义上是你们这十几年的时间逃避责任，
所以没有领结婚证，
但是这个钱实际上是夫妻共同的财产，
他并没有说就你替他还。
我今年32岁，
我老公他也是32岁，
现在有一个儿子，
一个女儿，
女儿11岁，
儿子2岁，
在我们2015年刚生第一个孩子的时候，
我老公他因为一个交通事故跟对方打官司，
就要赔付，
可能是90多万块钱吧，
保险的话，
当时还像买的就是个50万的，
最后就是我们自己还要出30万块钱嘛，
那个时候我们还比较小，
他22岁，
他家里面一直也没有给他出一分钱，
这个事情就是放到现在已经10年了，
就一直没有去解决，
撞伤了还是撞死了，
撞伤了撞到那三级残废，
那人家没有申请强制执行吗？
申请了强制执行的，
但是因为他家里面给钱嘛，
然后一直没有解读，
到了第二年的话，
因为我家里面我爸妈是开厂的，
爸妈就让我来他厂里面给我妈干了一年，
到了第二年的话，
我爸就一直带着我们，
我们就相当于自己做了，
然后创业这几年也挺辛苦的，
经过我们自己的努。
你现在工厂的规模也还可以吧，
前段时间的话，
对方现在又起诉了，
可能是找了个律师，
协调的话是协调到25万块钱，
然后他妈妈说了他出10万块钱，
我老公说我们厂里面有钱，
就没让她爸妈出嘛，
但是我们这十年一直就没有领结婚证，
她爸爸给我们厂里面当司机，
她妈妈给我带孩子，
我也是给她出费用的，
一年大概四十十万块钱左右吧，
干来有三四年，
每年工资都付给他了，
她老公她现在她自己的话，
呃，
身体也不太好，
也有什么肝炎，
那你想问的问题是啥呀？
如果我把她这个钱给他还了之后，
我们是不是要去领结婚证了，
这个手上的财产可以去怎么保护好？
在一起的第一年，
她就跟别的女的在聊天，
在我怀孕的期间，
现在她觉得自己生意做的也还可以，
天天也跟那些老板在一起，
我打牌等一下，
去KTV啊，
去洗脚那些，
我问你，
你手上有多少存款，
两三百万吧，
这两三百万是你们两口子这十几年攒下来的，
是不是对主要是靠这个男的挣钱的，
还是主要靠你挣钱呢？
我也是，
厂里面什么都管，
每天都干活，
每天都上班，
跟我第二个儿子的时候，
我上班都上到生他的前一，
天天都是管他，
厂里面的这些事情都是靠自己的，
也就是说钱，
资产全都在。
在你手里，
在你名下，
然后这个男的名下是没有任何资产，
没有任何的钱，
现在人家受伤害的那一方已经从原来的三五十万降到了25万了，
要求对方去还债，
还债这个事情你是怎么想的呢？
现在事情已经到了这个地步，
肯定要给他还了，
他爸爸也不那么喜欢乱花钱的，
他家里头什么也没有，
房子啦，
什么东西都没有，
肯定就只能我给他出了嘛，
是吧，
要了就是不出，
你这个观点是不对的，
这几百万的存款不是你一个人挣下来，
不是你去给人家还款，
其实某种意义上是你们这十几年的时间逃避责任，
所以没有领结婚证，
但是这个钱实际上是夫妻共同的财产，
他并没有说就你替他还，
你这个观念是不对的。
这几年前发生的事情，
不管怎么样，
这些年挣的钱没有放在男方的名下，
是为了逃避债务，
全都放在了你的名下，
不等于这些钱都归你所有，
讲道理吧，
因为这些年这个男的是在努力挣钱的，
这个只是没有放在男人的名下，
他为了逃避去赔付人家那个残疾的受害者，
所以把这些钱放在了你的卡里，
并不等于这些钱都是你的钱，
但是我们现在就是要去给他解决这个问题嘛，
解决完。
问题之后应该怎么办？
如果你不想跟人家过，
那么这个钱也要公平的分，
不是说这个钱存到你的卡里了，
就是你的了，
但是开这个产，
他家里面也没有出一分钱啊，
人家爸妈都在这儿干活，
人家男的也在这干活，
他爸妈在这里干活的话，
我每年都是给他开了工资的呀，
他妈妈给我带小孩，
我也都是付了钱的呀，
我跟你讲了，
今天你听我说这个话，
你心里会不得劲儿，
但是从你的人身安全，
从孩子的安全角度来说的话，
第一该给人家那个残疾人赔付，
就给残疾人赔付，
第二，
如果你要跟这个男的不想过了，
钱要公平一点分，
不能让这个男的到最后鸡飞蛋打，
所有钱都分不着，
你要是说你能听得进去，
说咱们保一个平安，
你要是听不进去，
就把人逼急了，
他10年白白的给你干活呀，
10年白白的就付出啊，
我现在只是担心，
我把这个钱付了之后，
他这个人我觉得没有那么靠谱，
我肯定不会说一分钱都不给他呀，
我只是怕给了钱他之后拿去外面又要欠钱，
我主要是怕是把这个钱之后再糟蹋了，
那你就不要领结婚证，
你旁边的人是你老公还是谁，
是我亲人，
我希望你的亲人能听得进去，
我讲的话一定是保平安的啊，
求什么，
求一个平安，
不然有钱也没命花，
能。
其实你看现在还有什么建议，
那他非要领结婚证呢，
非要领结婚证，
现在其实从法律上来说，
这些财产在你名下，
在你卡里，
从法律上来说确实是你的婚前个人财产，
那我弟弟跟你说一下吧，
他评论区说什么情况来啥的，
我每天都是干活的人，
我从来就不会搞那些东西，
让你弟弟说我以一个局外人的身份来说一下这个情况，
我姐夫他发生这个车祸这个事情啊，
他是在他怀孕期间带着女同事去吃饭，
然后我姐姐她觉得她不靠谱，
这个东西按理说是结婚之前就得处理好的，
她家里是一直拖着没有处理，
后面呢，
我爸爸就把她带到这个，
我们现在这个所在地带她创业，
因为我爸爸是有一定基础的，
可以说是我姐和我姐夫是我爸爸妈妈给他带上路的，
后面行情好的时候，
他是属于手上挣了一笔，
刚开始的时候吧，
感觉我姐夫也挺努力的，
那前几年开始行情比较好，
工厂规模扩大了，
感觉这个人也慢慢的就变了，
感觉自己是老板了，
跟那些同乡的老板去吃喝，
特别爱喝酒，
他身体还有一些疾病，
发炎了什么的，
挺危险的，
医生都说如果不管控的话，
活不过50岁，
我说白了就是爱吃，
今天喜欢出去玩，
如果说把他两个人这个对长里的贡献来划分的话，
我姐姐我觉得是能占到7，
然后她占到3，
想知道这个后续该怎么做嘛，
那就不要领结。
证，
如果他也认可，
他对厂里的付出占三分的话，
那么就现有的财产三七开，
如果他愿意的话，
那咱们就好聚好散，
结个善缘，
然后他分到他30%的财产，
之前交通肇事把人家搞成残废了，
他该还那个钱，
他的事情嘛，
就是他只挥继承人是让他结婚之前欠的债务，
但是你也说了，
这个场上的贡献占30%，
那就按这30%给人家分钱，
如果他也愿意的话，
咱们就是好聚好散，
结个善缘，
就不想把人逼到绝路上，
是这个意思，
那你姐姐还想说啥，
反正就是金融费律师了吧，
他家里面一家人有的时候都不靠谱，
他爸爸也是，
你看已经60岁了，
他家里面也是一分钱都没有，
我就怕我老公跟他爸爸一样，
就把这些钱全部挥霍了，
糟蹋了，
没了，
现在挣钱又这么难，
这两个人一调心什么的事情都可以干，
就是有的时候你觉得这个人就怕心不跟你在一块，
有的时候还想着怎么去瞒着你，
偷偷摸摸的，
这种就不喜欢。
第一，
他爸爸，
两个孩子的父亲，
如你们所言，
吃喝。
那么就不要跟他领结婚证，
不要跟他再纠缠在一起了，
为了你自己的身体健康，
为了自己不得病，
为了自己能有一个善终，
咱们以后就不要说领结婚证的事情了。
第二，
就算是跟他要分开，
在经济上咱们亲兄弟明算账，
如果你的这个男人，
他也认可他对厂子的贡献，
三七开，
你占七，
他占三，
那么我们钱也就三七分，
分到他手上的钱，
他自己拿去还债，
哪怕他用来吃喝，
都是他的因果，
否则的话，
你这个钱不分到他的手里，
他永远觉得你欠我的，
永远觉得我将来有什么事儿，
我还得找你，
还得找你们，
明白吗？
行，
你和你的两个孩子怎么才能得安生，
怎么才能得安宁？
他现在又身体又不好，
他活不过50岁，
他还天天说啊，
生死有命，
他就这样子说，
如果你不把钱分到位的话，
人家反正我活不过50岁啊，
我光脚的不怕穿鞋的，
难道你们就不担心，
难道你全家吗？
就是怕他分了钱给他，
分了钱给他，
好聚好散了，
咱们走到哪里也能说得通了，
分了钱给他以后，
他把钱挥霍了，
他怎么怎么样了，
这是他的事情，
你如果把钱都把在手里的话，
他不会放过你的。
行，
好的，
知道了，
好，
那就这样，
我知道此时。
此刻啊，
就算跟我连麦的这个人，
也未必能够理解我的苦心，
也未必听了我这个话心里就是舒坦的，
未必说花了这300块钱他心里就舒坦，
就高兴了。
但是你从长远来看的话，
从现有的这个社会的案件吧，
从社会现在的这个经济条件来看的话，
我的这个方案它是保命的方案，
就是姐妹们没有命，
有再多钱有屁用啊，
没有命花呀，
不要去拿自己和孩子的命去冒这样的风险，
拿全家人的命去冒这样的风险，
他这种人给人撞残了都能躲十年的人，
他能狠心到什么程度？
他有良心吗？
他这种人有良知吗？
我问你，
没有良知的人，
你跟他谈什么？
你更要利益分的清楚一点，
更要让他觉得他没有吃亏。
我这么判断没毛病吧，
他但凡是一个有良知的人，
他吃香的喝辣的吃喝，
他把人家撞成残废了，
他躲了10年都不肯出钱，
你跟这样的狠人，
你还想跟他掰扯不要命了吗？
你跟他掰扯什么？
他不是狠角色是什么？
记得点赞关注哦。